but today they're getting ready for a
huge weekend getting ready for mother's
day
they're open today and tomorrow and they
have some deals and joining us live here
we have kate she's going to show us a
few things that they have to offer for
this weekend
including a cone with some pops good
morning good morning cake pops
yes exactly cake pops so we're gonna
make our cake pop cone
so i'm just gonna show you guys real
quick we get four
firsts and then we end it with our fifth
and so a mama can either share or eat
them all
and you also have a deal with some
cookies for just two dollars each is
that right we do we call them our mama
cookies
and they're heart-shaped cookies that
say mama on them
and we have them today and tomorrow for
two dollars
and so you've been busy these last few
days getting ready for this big day
for business yes sir exactly you know we
got to care about our mamas they're so
special
so it's busy for sure now just as a side
note tell us about the tea parties
so we host little princess parties and
princes can come
and they dress up they do a craft they
have pink sparkly tea
finger sandwiches and can even dress up
it's so cool in here
you know you see pink everywhere and
it's so enchanting
well thank you so much yes pink pink is
definitely a great
color and if you look really close
you'll see some sparkle because our
motto is if it doesn't sparkle it
doesn't matter
thank you very much so you know again
we're at tivoli village we're going to
hop over to another shop and highlight
another local business
and the deals they have to offer for
this busy mother's day weekend for now
reporting live
hector mejia and kate back to you guys
we have to borrow that mantra i think if
it doesn't sparkle it doesn't matter
because they last vegas
i love that